a short time ago I talked with judge
Cavanaugh's attorney beth wilkinson
there are now calls not only the senate
minority leader chuck schumer but all
ten Democrats on the Senate Judiciary
Committee are calling for Kavanagh to
withdraw his nomination is he
considering that at all no he's not and
it's very unfortunate that it's come to
this today I'm shocked by the
allegations that were just extraordinary
that they were just dropped on the
public today and on the committee if you
read those allegations they mean that
tens and tens of men and women were
involved with gang rape and binge
drinking and all that goes along with
that for years and no one reported it
and no one reported it since Judge
Cavanaugh has been in this process if
this allegation has merit I don't
understand why her attorney didn't bring
it forward before and why he hasn't gone
to the police the Democrats are saying
why not just put the brakes on
everything and tell the FBI to reopen
this background investigation I mean
that's up to the Senate Judiciary
Committee to size up to judge Cavanaugh
it's really not for me it's really not
he's part of this process the Senate is
in charge of this process they've run
the investigation they run the hearing
he has said what he knows which is he
absolutely didn't do this he doesn't
even know this woman and he has
submitted himself to questions under the
penalty of perjury over and over again
he said repeatedly he's never engaged in
this kind of conduct and I wonder why
these people didn't come forward when
Judge Cavanaugh has been in the
limelight for months months and if they
thought that these allegations had any
merit they should have come forward
before and there would have been plenty
of time to do whatever they want to do
but you have to question the motives
when they come forward with the most
salacious most outrageous allegations
the day before the hearing senator flake
said today on the speech on the floor
that no matter what happens even if they
get to a yes and no vote that this is
going to have some doubt surrounding it
I understand what he's saying because
this process what it's become is so
demeaning and degrading for our country
I don't know why anyone would ever want
to put their name in the Hat for a
public office name if we're going to do
this to people I think there is going to
be a pail over everyone
for how they participated in this and it
you wouldn't hall out and make
accusations against someone the day
before they were going in front of a
hearing you just wouldn't do that normal
people even when they're opposed to
judge Cavanaugh which again they have
every right to be we'd never do that and
so it just makes everybody look like you
know they're politicizing the Supreme
Court and the and the approval process
I've talked to a lot of people they say
it just feels bad to them no matter what
side you're on
listening to judge Cavanaugh and his
wife on that interview with Martha the
other night is he more indignant
angry I know he's he's very upset about
it because he knows he didn't do it but
you know he's a judge he's not a
television person he's not a trial
lawyer like I am and so he's not used to
talking about these things and being on
television and it's I think embarrassing
in front of his family and his two
daughters to talk about you know that he
drank at times in excess when he was in
college about dating girls and what
happened it's not a comfortable position
for him that doesn't mean he doesn't
have to answer the questions he
understands that comes with the job
interview and he's not saying feel sorry
for him but yes he's he's he's outraged
by this most recent allegation because
it suggests that for years years there
was gang rape going on and no one said
anything of multitude of women and you
know a large number of men were involved
it doesn't say actually he was involved
it says he was present which he was not
he doesn't even know this woman but this
is a whole different level of allegation
we're in this environment obviously
people are being told that they need to
come forward two out of three don't
really talk about it but here you have
the end of the line and there are a
number of women coming forward well I
don't I mean I think some of the women
didn't want to come forward as I
understand it for dr. blazing forward
she didn't want to come forward and
someone leaked her name I feel sorry for
her I feel sorry for anyone who's
associated with this process a mark
judge who judge Kavanagh was friends
with you know some of the other people
who weren't supposedly at this party
that everyone says did not happen and
and they don't recall it and it's of
course not consistent with Judge Gavin
are what they know about him and what he
did way back in high school in college
but everybody is demeaned by this
process and somebody leaked that
information I don't understand why this
information with you know by brought
forward by mr. avenatti was you know
held back until today and I think I
understand why it makes everyone feel
uncomfortable because sexual assault is
a very serious claim and it's difficult
for women to talk about it and it
shouldn't be politicized on either side
it is not fair to the women and it's not
fair to the men who can be accused or
wrongly accused so when they keep saying
it needs to be investigated by the FBI
what is the thought in your corner why
didn't they call the police when the day
mr. avenatti started representing her no
one stopped him from going to the police
or the FBI in fact as I understand it
the Senate Judiciary Committee just sent
him the phone numbers of the FBI he
knows what he's doing
also today the lawyer for dr. Blasi Ford
ahead of this testimony tomorrow put out
said she's not gonna put out the medical
records and the notes but she did put
out the polygraph that she apparently
took on August 7th that comes to the
conclusion according to this paperwork
that it's not indicative of deception
her answers to this polygraph does that
many many I think to you you know that
was up to dr. Blasi and again she she
you know has her reasons for not wanting
to come forward before and and that's
that's up to her but the notes from her
that I read about in The Washington Post
were that there were notes that her
therapist made in in couples therapy and
that they don't seem to match up with
what people are saying about what
happened now and so those would be
relevant because that was the first time
she supposedly ever talked about this
and I would have hoped that they would
turn over the notes but of course
they're saying their medical records
they don't want to do that again that's
up to them you know she obviously said
she wanted to be anonymous but yet in
August takes a polygraph hires an
attorney what is the thinking about the
reasoning behind that
I think what's that here is that judge
Kavanagh knows that he didn't do this
and when these allegations come out at
the last minute it's almost impossible
you know to disprove when someone says
it at the last minute is he worried that
she's going to come off as credible in
this hearing and that they're gonna lose
one or two votes
he's not thinking about her other than I
think he you know understands that she
didn't want to be public about this
either he wants to come forward in front
of the American public and explain that
he didn't do this and he'll answer any
questions that the Senate Judiciary
Committee has and he'll tell the truth
and that's the best he can do it doesn't
like the process how it's turned out but
he understands that you know that's his
obligation and he's going to do it and
he's answer those questions before and
he'll answer them again and does he
worry at all about getting onto the
Supreme Court and then somehow this
doesn't stop and that they go after him
continually for impeachment or something
else well I think we all worry that if
we lose the dignity of the process it
can affect the Supreme Court and
everybody involved but I think at this
point he has had investigation after
investigation for background he's had a
long period where the public was allowed
to look at him you know ask questions
for the Judiciary Committee senators
have asked him questions in public and
in private
all that's taken place and all that was
there for a reason we we are there two
people are there to decide what they
think and whether the Senators will vote
for him or not and they're allowed to do
that but it can't be that when people
make last-minute allegations and throw
you know character assassination at him
that therefore the the answer is to step
back and to not you know go for it these
people deserve to have their hearing and
the senators deserve to vote as they
think they should and he's in it for the
long haul
yes I mean you know it's been awful for
him and his family and his daughters but
it's been worse I think he feels worse
for the American public and for the
process